the website initially directed me to a
test center in beijing stoke that i
know isn't there and had actually been
closed down some weeks ago
every time i went on the met the message
said
uh tests not available or wait a few
hours
and try again the nearest testing center
with available appointments
was 92 miles away i'm a healthcare
professional trying to get back to work
i've been told i can't go back unless i
get a negative result
there are no home tests available a
testing system
under strain but why the health
secretary blamed
people getting tested in the last couple
of weeks we
have seen an increase in demand
including an increase in demand from
people who are not eligible for tests
people who don't have symptoms officials
have also said there are problems with
lab processing whatever the reason
testing has become a struggle
looking at this testing center in south
london you would never guess there was
intense demand for tests
i mean look at it it is quiet
but weirdly that's exactly what the
government wants it's
artificially restricting the supply of
tests
to push testing capacity away from
places like this
towards other parts of the country and
that's why
if you try and book a test in this area
right now
you're told that despite this emptiness
there's nothing available
that might make sense nationally to
frustrated parents
it feels like the signs haven't been
clear
steve drove two ill children to a
testing center
only to be turned away people don't
drive for hours on the end
to shove cotton buds up their nose and
into the back of their mouths for fun
they're doing this because they're
scared and because there isn't a clarity
of message coming from government
it's in this context that the prime
minister announced a bold new plan for
mass testing
suggesting people could get a test
before going to the panto or the office
even if the technology comes through
experts are doubtful
about its merits i think it's it's
possible
but actually i would almost question
whether it's desirable
um and actually i think it comes back to
this we don't have a coherent strategy
for how we're doing
try and tackle this disease and we seem
just to be throwing numbers and
sound bites and quotes at it we get
frustrated at that because what we want
is a coherent testing strategy
to deal with what we are facing at the
moment with cases rising fast
the government sees testing as one of
its most important tools
trouble is right now everything is going
slow
roland manthal sky news